The Speedforce this time we're not going to necessarily
See Barry's experience in the Speedforce
We'll see kind of the effects that the speedforce has had on barry and he's been in there six months real-time
But the way, I see it is the speed Force is kind of nonlinear with time, so barry is experienced
Kind of his entire life from start to end infinity times over since he's been in there
So he's going to have kind of an awakening when he comes out
He's going to be I think he's got some knowledge that he probably doesn't even quite understand yet
He'll also be a little scrambled. He won't really be himself the first time we see him
Hey everybody flash is almost back Grant Gustin is talking about barry coming out of the speed Force with all kinds of new Knowledge, and
abilities
So let's break it down
There were also a bunch of you asking about the negative flash who has all these crazy new powers in the comics
I'll explain that after I talk about flash season four stuff because I'm not
Because, im not expecting a whole bunch of that to happen on the TV show this year. Negative speed Force is a slightly different concept
And the whole idea is that they're trying not to go back to that speedster well again.
So they'll probably save negative speed force for the next time the reverse flash gets a big story
But all the rebirth stuff that grant Gustin's been hyping up has served a couple important functions
One that they start the new season with a new version of Barry that can just dump all the baggage from the previous season
So no more moping barry sad crying about things that he can't change or trying to change things in getting that "damn it barry"
response from all his friends. Even candice patton was
Joking that they should rename the show "Damn it Barry"
Because so much of the show just turns on all the mistakes that he's made the last couple of seasons
"Flashpoint - Damn it Barry"
How dare you. Didn't we have this lesson during season one?
So grant Gustin the producers are saying that all that bullsh** is gone
You show up with a new version of barry that's lived what seems like several lifetimes
In the span of the last couple months since we last saw him go into the speed force
So it's sort of like the 'Etch-a-Sketch' way to fix your character
It's a really clever way, too, because it makes sense the speed Force is a place that exists Beyond space-time
So if somebody went in and came out with a completely different personality, it would actually make sense
So he'll still be 'The Flash'
He's still the comic book flash, but the writers the actors don't have to hang on to any of the stuff
They feel like didn't work out or didn't really go the way. They wanted to last season. Like the big comment
Is that they waited too long to do the Savitar reveal - things got a little too dark, a little too depressing. He just comes back
Now and he's a completely different person. Boom. Poof. Problem
solved.
You've probably heard them referencing season one a lot. Like, we really like the way season 1 felt. It was exciting to be the flash
to learn about all these new
abilities every single week, so
number 2: Barry comes out of the speed Force, and he can do that again because, like Grant gustin says in this interview, he doesn't
fully understand everything. He has all this new information
And he just has to start to sift through it. That's actually happening on game of thrones right now
He comes out of the speed Force with ultimate knowledge and abilities
But doesn't completely understand how to use it or how to access it on command
So you get your upgraded more powerful version of the flash, in the future flash costume, big costume upgrade right off the bat;
But week to week you also get to see him discover new abilities like oh my God
I didn't know I could do that
So there's a lot of cool abilities from the comics that they could choose to do on the TV show. Most of them are
Destructive abilities which I'm not expecting. Like you know the finger-snap
He can create sonic booms when he snaps his finger - The reason why they probably don't do that is because they'd have to replace all
Those windows every time they wanted to shoot a scene, so that's probably why you haven't seen that on-screen yet.
But the whole idea is that the new powers that you see each season have something to do with him fighting the villain. So if
This Season's villain is The Thinker, then they'll probably be more mental-based powers
So what I'm expecting is, is it'll be a slightly upgraded version where he can retain anything that he reads for 30 minutes.
So he can become an expert on anything for up to 30 minutes
So if The Thinker is so much smarter and
Complicated than villains that he's faced before, he's going to have to learn how to be a better detective -
which is one of the reasons why they probably chose to go with The Elongated Man; because in the comics
he's a detective too. And what have we not seen on The Flash the last couple of seasons?
Barry doing really good CSI work. Like most of the CSI stuff last season was all Tom Felton's character
So they said they're going back to season 1 vibe. What did he do to during season one?
He did a lot of CSI work
So it sounds like he'll be using new abilities to aid in Detective work
But there are also a couple of other abilities that are really easy for them to do on screen
One of the new ones that they showed off during season 3, that barry never really figured out, was how to travel
extra fast using the speed Force as a conduit. So normally the flash runs through
Three-dimensional space like he just runs from 'point a' to 'point b' as fast
as he can but - there's all kinds of drags, heat buildup and any mental obstacles that he might have. The
Fastest way to run is actually to jump into the speed force,
which exists beyond space time, and then just jump back out whichever point you want to be at. So that's how you could go across
the Earth in an instant. He wouldn't run across the Earth
He would sort of tunnel through the speed Force, the way that we saw Savitar do in the first couple of episodes.
And also another ability is a way to passively borrow and give speed to other speedsters
So like he and Wally are helping out on a problem, and he needs to help Wally be faster
He can just grant Wally a portion of his speed or vice versa
But when you're thinking about new abilities for the flash to have, just remember that he's fighting The Thinker, and he's not so much like
a big villain like Zoom, that he would just try to outrace or punch in the face
He's a master mind character playing four dimensional chess. So barry has to learn how to play chess better
using his speed Force abilities
But obviously it's a television show, so it's not going to be the two of them sitting at a table all season
So let me know in the comments, which other new powers do you want to see him use during this season?
He's already done most of the things we've seen the flash do, but he has to go full Neo. Like, if you've read that
original Thinker arc that Geoff Johns wrote, it reads very much like the Matrix movie, in that story, the flash winds up beating him
inside digital space - not in physical space. And normally, that'd be a big disadvantage for him. But as of right now,
I believe they're finishing filming episode 4, maybe beginning episode 5. We've already seen The Elongated Man on set;
that's who this actor is.
There's been no mention of Sue Dibny, so I'm expecting it'll just be him and it might be before he meets her. Maybe she's
dead, and it's some sort of tragic thing. Like, Kaitlin lost Ronnie during season 1. Like, "my girlfriend died in the particle accelerator explosion"
So we'll see about that
But I think he's going to be 'what you see is what you get' with the exception of the powers. Like wow, you have some
crazy abilities. You look kind of like Mr. Fantastic. So I'm expecting all kinds of memes when he debuts on the show
I think it's going to be either episode 3 or episode 4
It's not going to be right away
But as for 'Negative Flash,' like moving into pure comic-book stuff - if you haven't been reading the flash comic book
Reverse flash tried to trap barry in the negative speed Force, it
backfired, he became infused with the negative speed force, and came out almost with a completely different personality;
completely different powers.
It's almost like he's been poisoned and now he's trying to learn how to use those new abilities and figure everything out
But his speed Force energy, he calls it
unpredictable, the negative speed force when it leaves speed trails will just blow stuff up. It's this really explosive force
So he takes down some criminals
And then turns around to see what's happened in the wake of their run
And he winds up causing way more damage himself than any of the criminals did. Like, he literally rips the street apart
So it makes you wonder if that's part of the reason why the reverse flash was such an asshole
Because barry suddenly gets a lot madder. It's almost like he's been on steroids. Like, the smallest thing will set him off
He's much quicker to anger. "I'm mad," so you see this face here, and you're like, okay..
He looks exactly like the reverse flash here
Maybe these are some of the things that made the reverse flash such an evil person. So like I said
I'm not expecting the TV show to ever address this stuff this season without the presence of the reverse flash
And they haven't said exactly when he's coming back. Right now, odds are after the mid-season finale
And they'll just spend most of the first half of the season
Dealing with all the new barry stuff like oh my God everything's new Barry's a little bit different. He has new powers
There's a couple new characters
There's a new villain called the thinker then the second half of the season then they'll start to bring back some of the really big
Stuff, but we do know that gorilla grodd for instance is going to Guest star a lot on legends of tomorrow
He'll be one of the bigger villains of that season, so that'll be pretty cool
So lots of flash stuff happening all over the 'Arrowverse.' So leave all your requests for flash videos in the comments below
I'll say congratulations to the latest Giveaway winner coby
Shank you win a flash ring
Please private message me on the back end of my channel so I can get your contact details
There was a new round in this video
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
Leave a comment on the video
And while you wait for everything you can click here to rewatch that New Justice league trailer
And you can click here for brand new game of thrones. Thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight